ich würde sagen ich fange hier mit dem
mango stück an
ich glaube ich nicht war das wirklich
spülmittel etwas gehabt und jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt gut
heute ein kleines video in form eines
blogs gut geht
ich habe auf jeden fall heute morgen
kost bekommen
hier das ist so ein fake louie vito
pulli ich habe ja damals dieses video
gemacht wo ich bei juve tor bestellt
habe und die sachen sind einfach jetzt
erst angekommen
das ist schon bestimmt zwei monate her
also voll heftig hätte ich niemals
gedacht dass das so lange gedauert aber
jetzt gibt es bald mal das video dazu
auf jeden fall was machen wir heute ja
ihr habt es wahrscheinlich schon an
titel gelesen es geht heute um so schien
und zwar wurde mir letztens auf der
youtube startseite ein video angezeigt
von einer youtube drin wie sie so ski
probiert hat und ich habe mich irgendwie
so ein bisschen selber darin wieder
gesehen ich verlängere ich dass viele
natürlich in der video beschreibung und
ich bin halt so ein mensch ich habe bis
zu meinem ich würde mal sagen
siebzehnten lebensjahr recht nur sehr
sehr wenig gegessen ich mochte auch
viele sachen einfach gar nicht also
jetzt so sachen wie fisch habe ich nie
angerührt ich fand den geruch nicht gut
deswegen habe ich auch nicht probieren
von viel gemüse wie tomaten gurken
es gibt noch also tomaten und gurken
habe ich auch auf kleinsten angefasst
ich hatte in meiner kindheit und meiner
jugend eigentlich so standard sachen die
ich halte immer gegessen habe und ich
wollte gar nicht irgendwas neues
ausprobieren das hat mir gereicht und
ich fand alles andere auch sofort
täglich wenn wir irgend jemand etwas
anderes hingehalten hat was ich vorher
noch nie gesehen habe habe ich gesagt
nee story mag ich nicht
es gibt einige sachen die ich in meinem
leben wirklich noch nie gegessen habt
dazu zählt auch sushi und das hat sich
bis heute durch gezogen weil ich es
irgendwie echt unappetitlich finde wenn
man es anschaut wenn man es recht gut so
richtig gerochen habe ich noch gar nicht
aber ich habe mich für das heutige video
überlegt wir fahren jetzt gleich einfach
hier um die ecke ist so ein sushi laden
irgendwie ich glaube dass auch so eine
kette oder so da gehe ich jetzt gleich
hin
ich habe absolut keine ahnung was das
für verschiedene arten gibt ich nehme da
einfach so ein paar sushi würfel mit und
probiere einfach mal
ich will ja gestern vorbei gefahren hat
das einkommen macht das sommer und jetzt
wollte ich will gar nicht eingeladen wir
fahren sofort mal los und schreibt mal
gerne in die kommentare ob ihr sushi
gerne mit oder nicht also hier
vielleicht nur kurz zu ski ist ein
japanisches gericht ausgesagt im reis
ergänzt um weitere zutaten zutaten genau
ergänzt und weitere zutaten wie ronan
oder geräucherten fisch oder
meeresfrüchten gemüse blava und was ist
das denn tofu ach so na ja ich finde ich
echt nicht so lecker aber vielleicht bin
ich auch total überrascht ich bin
gespannt
so leute ich bin jetzt auf dem weg zur
band the police oder so zu fuß da vorne
ist so ich habe jetzt hier zu bekommen
also ist jetzt zwei verschiedenen
gerichte für zehn euro 70
was geht also leute ich habe gerade
schon gesagt das ganze als zehn euro 70
gekostet ich habe zwei gerichte gestellt
ich habe glaub ich hab gesagt ziemlich
teuer
aber ich meinte eigentlich nur wenn ich
mir jetzt die menge angucke 14 eur 70 so
ein paar kringel da unten relativ teuer
also das ganze sieht jetzt so aus so wie
ich das auch könner aus irgendwelchen
filmen oder bildern was jetzt dieses
zeug oder das hier ist weiß ich nicht
habe ich vorher noch nie gesehen dass
ich irgendwie bisschen aus wie knete und
warum ich ketchup das ist es überhaupt
geht shop und hier haben wir auch so
stäbchen glaub ich ja genau
wie soll ich denn jetzt hier mit dass in
meinem mund kriegen
es geht doch gar nicht okay wir machen
es mal kurz auf das riecht irgendwie
ziemlich scharf bevor ich anfange das zu
essen will ich sagen gibt es erst mal
ein kleines video damit ihr seht was das
genau ist
[Musik]
okay leute das habe ich gerade schon und
diese ausnahme gemacht und jetzt ist
wirklich an der zeit jetzt kann ich
loslegen hier so ich habe ja immer
folgendes bestellt erst mal hab ich
gefragt hier kann ich einfach acht
verschiedene so schießt nehmen weil man
sowieso also die sagte wahrscheinlich
was ist das denn für einer
der kennt sich ja überhaupt nicht aus
aber ich war halt vorher noch nie so
shears und deswegen haben wir jetzt
einmal acht mauerstücke und 6 lachs
irgendwas dazu ganz einfach hier knete
und so ein bisschen sauerkraut oder ich
habe keine ahnung was das ist hier in
dem steht finde ich schon so ein bischen
reis das probiere ich jetzt mal das
schmeckt ja schon mal gar nicht so
schlecht ich würde sagen ich fange hier
mit dem mango stück an einfach weil ich
fisch nicht so gerne mag
wie das jetzt genau funktioniert weiß
ich nicht ob man das ganze im mund
nehmen muss oder nicht weiß ich auch
nicht
ich glaube ich nicht
[Musik]
war lecker also hier muss ich sofort
schon mal sagen bin sehr positiv
überrascht das war wirklich lecker ich
weiß zwar nicht so genau was das hier
ist oder dass hier aber es war gar nicht
schlecht hier haben wir jetzt eine soße
ich mache jetzt einfach scheiße war das
jetzt richtig oder nicht
sowieso ist es jetzt ein bisschen
darüber verteilt und ich würde sagen wir
gehen über obwohl kaum einer geht noch
auf mache ich das überhaupt gerade
richtig mit diesen studien oder komplett
falsch denn hier nehmen wir auch noch
mit und dazu noch ein bisschen knete war
das echt also wenn man den einfach mal
so nebenbei ist komplett das war heftig
okay also alle von euch das auch noch
nie probiert haben
ich bin sehr positiv überrascht von der
mango minze nähe von der mango mit sushi
was auch immer das mal eben was mit
mango als nächstes probieren wir erzählt
diesen lachs häppchen
da würde ich jetzt wirklich mal gespannt
augen zu und durch
[Musik]
das ist gar nicht mein fall das war so
übertrieben sich man hat den lachs
überhaupt nicht raus geschmack als er
einfach nach versalzt umreißt ich mir
also die hier würde von mir wirklich
acht punkte kriegen von 10 und die ihr
so einen zum schluss würde ich sagen
probier mal dieses kraut ja auch noch
mal vor dass wirklich spülmittel
wer ist so was das kann man nicht essen
jetzt habe ich gerade überlegt ob das
dann tourist zum hände sauber machen
aber das war ja auch nicht sein
das riecht wie das ist infektionen ich
würde sagen sie zum abschluss geht doch
mal sondern seinen mango teil wird durch
lala kamen angerufen ja hier hat ein
video gemacht also das schmeckt das
alles vor sich also bis hierhin ich
glaube das schmeckt auch alles so ein
bisschen salzig wegen dieser soße hier
keine ahnung was das ist aber die ist
nicht zu empfehlen die ersten beiden
stücke machen würde ich gegessen habe
war echt lecker die lachs schicke habe
ich gar nicht gefeiert die mango stücke
ich jetzt gerne noch auf mit dem hier
kann ich auch nichts anfangen also ein
paar mankos es auf jeden fall mal gerne
bin ich positiv überrascht gewesen den
rest mussten hier sind heute schreibt
gerne mal in die kommentare ob ihr so
schmeckt oder nicht ob jetzt auch noch
nie probiert habe so wie ich weil ich
glaube so die sache die die meisten
menschen noch nicht probiert haben so in
europa ist bestimmt sushi das war es mit
dem video und diesen sushi teller stelle
ich jetzt meine mitbewohner schön
vorzimmer damit der duft so ein bisschen
nach ein ziel aber die lachse die
duftete schön und dann türschlitz er ins
zimmer ein spaß das wars mit dem video
last noch nach oben da wir sehen uns
morgen eventuell wieder ich glaub's
nicht sondern eher sonntag also leute
haut rein
ach ja was ich noch sagen wollte ab
jetzt gibt es immer montags mittwochs
freitags und sonntag ein video montags
und mittwochs jeweils um 19 uhr freitags
und sonntags jeweils um 14 ich habe mir
einen kleinen plan gemacht einfach damit
ist viel einfacher ist für mich haut
rein